so all of these networks here they
probably appear to be legitimate right
yeah but they're not these are all fake
networks they're all powered by me so as
soon as you connect to any of those I
have your password I have anything in
between oh man so this is is this how
people are stealing information yeah it
is in this video the number one ethical
hacker explains how hackers get your
credentials while you're using public
networks so what is this attack called
it's called a man in the middle attack
so if I'm on the same network as you I
can essentially control the traffic you
know as if I was the modem or router so
instead of when you type google.com
instead of your computer telling the
router you want google.com you're
telling my computer you want google.com
and I'm giving you what I what I'm
telling you google.com is it would be
called a DNS attack yep that's mad Ryan
probably used a flipper zero Wi-Fi Dev
board for this trick that's why we never
use public Wi-Fi what about you follow
some sub to know more about security